are you a fast and furious fanatic have
you ever considered what these movies
would be like if Disney got a hold of
them okay most people haven't but once
you entertain the idea you just might
want to see what these movies would be
like well get ready because we are full
of ideas for a Disney pixarified Fast
and Furious franchise
so celebs love to test out their voice
acting chops in animated films almost as
much as we love to recognize their
familiar voices while we're watching
them so the first thing we're sure about
for a fast and furious Disney remake is
an animated version of Dom Toretto with
Vin Diesel reprising his role this time
of course diesel will just be providing
the voice as for how he looks we can
picture Dom looking a little something
like a hairless version of Mariano from
Encanto everything okay it just fits as
far as we're concerned and while we've
seen
actually be far from the first time Vin
Diesel has provided the voice for an
animated character he played the titular
character in The Iron Giant I am not a
gun as well as Groot in the Guardians of
the Galaxy franchise
so not only do we know that no one else
could play Dom quite like he can but we
know he'll be able to pull it off even
if we can't see him come on who doesn't
love groot's voice
he says welcome to the freaking
Guardians of the Galaxy while plenty of
folks would argue that Vin Diesel is one
of the biggest parts of the Fast and
Furious movies most of us would agree
that it's actually the cars cars are a
big part of Fast and Furious hence the
name but we think that the film's cars
need a major change to fit into the
Disney Universe like for starters We're
not gonna have to bring these cars to
life like well the movie Cars sure the
cars in Cars don't actually have people
driving them and that's an important
part of Fast and Furious so that
complicates the anthropomorphizing of
the vehicles just a little bit but we
think the new Fast and Furious franchise
can include a bit of buddy cop dynamic
between between the cars and their
drivers of course all of the coolest
cars will make an animated appearance
speaking of which if you happen to love
cool cars making animated appearances
your favorite celebs making TV
appearances or like basically anything
else interesting in the TV and movie
world now is the perfect time to like
And subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one fans of the
original The Fast and the Furious film
know that car hijackers are a pretty big
plot point of the movie yet since this
version will have sentient cars there's
certainly a new Twist on the whole
carjacking thing it's pretty difficult
to adapt that first film without
including car hijackers but since these
cars now have personalities this will be
more of a kidnapping slash Ransom
situation in the Disney version and of
course things will have to work out for
the best because well it's family
friendly drifting is an important part
of the Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift
and since the cars now have their own
opinions we think it's only logical that
the cars themselves now love to drift
come on even as non-cars we can admit
that that looks pretty fun it's like
roller skating for vehicles and speaking
of Tokyo Drift We can't help but picture
what the city Chase scenes would look
like if Pixar actually got a hold of
them we can imagine Disney slash Pixar
animating a version of Tokyo beautifully
but we wonder whether it may be even
more interesting for them to create a
Fantastical new city like they have
plenty of times before we've seen some
amazing fictional animated cities in
plenty of different movies and TV shows
from zootopia to porterosso from Luca of
course all of our favorite animated
cities have borrowed some obvious inspo
from real life cities if Disney Pixar
created a new fictional city for their
own Fast and Furious franchise we can
only imagine how cool this city would
look as the cars cruised around in it
and we think a Tokyo inspired brand new
city would make for a super cool
addition to the movies so while some
elements of the franchise like the cool
set are easy to translate into a family
friendly version there's only one
elephant in the room that isn't the
element in question well Too Fast Too
Furious has some pretty adult themes
like you know crime boys enjoy the show
those who know Fast and Furious know
that this one will also need some PG
rating if buying so the Disney version
will have to change a few things to make
this a bit more family friendly we think
theft is a fine concept to leave in a
Disney movie like what kid hasn't seen
home alone right but in any particularly
violent moments will have to be altered
oh and as for any car crashes since
these cards are now sentient we're gonna
have to curb the car crashes just a
little bit no pun intended car crashes
are either going to have to end with a
happy ending for the cards or they'll
have to teach a life lesson we all
remember how what happened to Doc Hudson
was handled in cars too sad yes
appropriate also yes Disney knows how to
do it so they'll have to make it happen
again for Too Fast Too Furious or should
we call it too fun too friendly now Fast
Five has some familiar faces and we
think their voices joining the cast
would make for another great crossover
for Fast and Furious and its animated
remake Michelle Rodriguez plays Letty in
the original Fast and Furious franchise
we feel like we'd recognize Rodriguez's
voice anywhere so why shouldn't she
reprise her role What's it gonna be
we're not the first folks to think she'd
fare well as a voice actor for an
animated film she provided the voice of
Paz for the 2013 DreamWorks movie Turbo
as well as smurfstorm in Smurfs the Lost
Village so Michelle Rodriguez is an Old
Pro at voice acting and she's got
another co-star in Fast Five who knows a
thing or two about voice acting like did
you know that Eva Mendes appeared on an
episode of The Beloved kids show Bluey
yep she played a yoga instructor lean
forward and raise that right leg off the
ground so we're thinking she should come
back to play Monica once more The Fast
and Furious franchise has had quite a
star-studded cast over its 22-year run
and we think that an animated version of
the franchise would welcome quite a few
of those familiar faces or should we say
voices as well as some new ones
while many things would change as a
result of the switch from action film
franchise to a series of animated
family-friendly flicks the themes about
the importance of family would be a
great Common Ground between the
franchises this is your family it's who
you are all fans know that the Fast and
Furious franchise loves family in fact
when added up altogether over the course
of Nine Movies family is mentioned a
whopping 75 times family family the
importance of loving and staying close
to your family is something that is
important for kids to learn about so we
think things like this would be ideal
for an updated franchise by the same
token you have to remember when Dom also
famously says I don't have friends
I got family and we think the concept of
found family and treating those you love
most the way you do your family is
another great lesson for plenty of kids
to learn like what better way to make
something family friendly than to talk
about how important family is right and
that's something fast and furious
already has going for it alright alright
we know what some of you may be thinking
if you've ever heard of a little
something called Fast and Furious by
Racers then you might be wondering wait
a second didn't they already do this
well the short answer is no but there
actually was an animated adaptation of
The Fast and Furious franchise in 2019 a
DreamWorks animated Netflix series
called Fast and Furious spy Racers
premiered the series ran for two seasons
and 52 episodes ending in 2021 rather
than being an actual animated adaptation
of The Fast and Furious film franchise
Fast and Furious spy Racers was more
like a spin-off of the movies it
followed a group of crime-fighting
teenagers the leader of the group was
Tony Toretto who just so happened to be
the cousin of a certain someone who goes
by the name of Dom and like the fact
that they were teenagers helped solve
some of the innate problems with making
the Fast and Furious movies a bit more
family friendly but we've got to admit
we're still holding out for that Disney
Pixar version but what do you think
about this idea what would you like to
see in a Disney version of The Fast and
Furious franchise let's chat about it in
the comments and for more videos like
this one remember to like And subscribe
to the things